Donald Trump had another one of these
Gong Show rallies yesterday and he told
a lot of lies in the rally that's not
really a surprise but he also said
something that's more than a lie or
something that is more interesting than
just a lie or truth either way whether
it's true or not it's idiotic Donald
Trump was in Pittsburgh he was giving a
speech about I guess on paper it was
supposed to be about energy but it's
Trump so it goes off the rails as usual
and Donald Trump said that his
administration is already building a
wall in New Mexico and in Colorado hear
it from the horse's mouth himself take a
listen we're building a wall on the
border of New Mexico and we're building
a wall in Colorado we're building a
beautiful wall a big one that really
works that he can't get over you can't
get under and we're building a wall in
Texas and we're not building a wall in
Kansas but they get the benefit of the
walls that we just mentioned he might
end up needing to use a sharpie to
modify a map I guess to put Colorado on
the Mexican border now if you look at a
map you might notice that yes New Mexico
does share a little bit of a border with
Mexico but the state of Colorado
does not so I don't know if Trump is
trying to keep people in Colorado
because of that legal weed or out of
neighboring states we may never really
know and of course people at Trump's
rally as you heard in that clip were
cheering when Donald Trump said he was
building walls in New Mexico and
Colorado why are they cheering like are
they just dumb do they want a wall
around Colorado separating Colorado from
other states
what about Denver's huge International
Airport into which planes can just fly
over the wall anyway how does Donald
Trump explain it it was all a joke
Trump was making subtle jokes despite
never having shown evidence of the type
of sense of humor that would allow a
subtle joke to be made Donald Trump
doing kiddingly
we're building a wall in Colorado then
stated we're not building a wall in
Kansas but they get the benefit of the
wall we're building on the
referred to people in the very packed
auditorium from Colorado and Kansas
getting the benefit of the border wall
can i what what is this guy talking
about what what an obviously ridiculous
explanation now what's more likely
Trump was using the type of subtle in
detectable humor which he's never
displayed evidence of being capable of
or Trump just had no idea where a walls
were getting built if anywhere maybe not
getting built is more like it and has
only a limited understanding of the
geography of the United States the
evidence says that the latter is
actually more likely the people of
Colorado by the way are more or less
sensible maybe they are the ones
building a wall to keep Trump out since
Trump seems to think walls keep people
out he might not realize if I want to go
to Colorado I can just fly into the
airport over the wall the best
explanation Colorado borders New Mexico
and maybe Trump is thinking that
Colorado should have a wall on its
southern border with New Mexico for
safety or something because anything
with the name Mexico in it clearly is
very very dangerous or something like
that
America in 2019 this is it's a sad place
this is a reality I is more analysis
necessary the one question to you is is
there anything else that I'm not
accounting for that maybe Donald Trump
meant when he said we're building a wall
around Colorado let me know leave her a
response if you're watching on youtube
send me a tweet at des Pakman